jantes aline bonjour les autorités
ukrainiennes dénonce précisément des
frappes russe contre la population
oui comme on peut le voir le nombre de
décès ne cessent d'augmenter pour
l'instant à crémone choc des centaines
de secouristes sur place car plus de
mille personnes se trouvaient dans ce
centre commercial du centre du pays où
les frappes ont causé un incendie qui
s'est propagé sur plus de dix mille
mètres carrés le président ukrainien a
qualifié cette attaque d'un des actes
terroristes les plus éhontés de
l'histoire européenne
la russie a déjà nié par le passé avoir
visé des lieux devise de civils c'est
notamment le cas avec l' attaque qui a
eu lieu à kiev ce dimanche dernier la
position du ministère de la défense
russe a été de dire qu'il s'agissait
d'un missile d'origine ukrainienne
pourtant les frappes intensifier de ces
derniers jours elles sont sans équivoque
plus d'une cinquantaine de tirs de
missiles ont été lancés de façon
éparpillés un peu partout dans le pays
très tôt ce matin des tirs de roquettes
ont atteint la ville de nicolet yeves
dans le sud du pays pas de dégâts
humains a déclaré pour l'instant mais
des immeubles résidentiels ont été
touchés la nuit dernière la deuxième
ville du pays arabes qui va encore à
nouveau et est frappé par des missiles
comme vous l'avez dit le président
hélène ce qui a annoncé appeler une
réunion du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
en toute urgence et ce matin un chiffre
terrible ce matin le haut commissaire
des nations unies aux droits de l'homme
a rapporté que plus de dix mille civils
auraient péri dans ce conflit en ukraine
qui a débuté avec l'invasion russe 24
février dernier voilà pour les frapper
puis il ya les combes les combats au sol
un tallinn la principale ligne de front
reste l'est de l'ukraine qu'elle est là
la situation dans cette région du monde
basse
et bien après s'être emparé sylvie
rodeau nièce qu'en fin de semaine
dernière les forces russes elles
concentrent leurs attaques désormais sur
la ville qui se trouve juste en face de
l'autre côté du fleuve d'eau n'y est la
ville de l'iscid chance que si la ville
tombe c'est toute la province du loup
danse qui tombera entre les mains des
ruches selon le ministère de la défense
britannique dans son rapport quotidien
elle affirme que les forces du craignent
elles consolident bien leur défense sur
les hauteurs de la ville et
et qu'elles mènent des opérations de
perturbations efficace ainsi que des
phrases bien d'avancer dans la ligne
russe mais malgré tout les forces russes
et pro russe elle avance même si tout
cela se déroule lentement le sort du
dombass en fait il va se jouer cet été à
quel rythme les forces russes feront
elles s'avancer vers la ville
stratégique et de cramât torse et
comment les autorités ukrainiennes les
forces du craignait ne vont elles
pouvoir faire face avec une contre
offensive efficace contre la puissance
de frappe russe qui est très très
importante pour les autorités
ukrainiennes la réponse est bien simple
cela fait des semaines que qu elle le
martèle qu'elles attendent de la part
des occidentaux plus d'armements lourds
ou le plus rapidement possible et c'est
armelle arrive certes mais cela prend du
temps que ce soit au niveau de la
logistique de l'acheminement de ces
armements ou bien de la formation des
soldats ukrainien à ces équipements plus
précis et plus efficace tallinn où des
gens depuis au dessin pour france24
merci beaucoup ta ligne justement cette
question de l'armement de la guerre en
ukraine en génie